welcome to the michaela peterson podcast
in this episode i spoke with lauren chan
lauren is a political and media
personality she has half a million
subscribers on youtube
and might be recognized from her
previous work as the roaming millennial
she reviews and creates content
primarily in the political spectrum but
is also branching into
other media avenues with her youtube
channel mediaholic
we discussed many a topic including
coveted restrictions in canada and the
u.s
whether or not university is worthwhile
how to stay sane during lockdowns
we're both in canada where it's insane
right now with lockdowns
lauren's top political issues lauren's
primary demographic
we also touched on her diet she brought
it up not me
and the canadian health care systems and
whether or not lizards
are better to have in houses than mice
the important topics
this episode was sponsored by ground
news
they're a canadian company that is a
comparison platform for news so rather
than trying to find an unbiased news
source
which is pretty much impossible although
some are certainly worse than others
ground news compares how sources from
across the political spectrum are
covering a story
so you can see whether or how an outlet
is changing the story to fit an
underlying narrative
and man 2020 had a lot of underlying
narratives
and 2021 isn't looking any better they
have an app called ground news for your
phone
so ground news is an apolitical news app
that you can use to give you all the
details of a story
regardless of your political ideology
you can download the app or visit
ground.news if you enjoy this episode
please remember to rate and subscribe
[Music]
lauren chen welcome to my podcast thank
you so much for having me i'm excited to
be here
so i usually start off by asking you to
give a brief background about who you
are and what it is that you do so let's
start off with that sure well i guess
i'm a social and political commentator
is the easiest way to describe it
and we were just talking about this
before the podcast started but i'm kind
of from all over the place
i was born in canada but my father is
from hong kong
and that's actually where i spent most
of my life growing up
and i was also an expat for a number of
years because of my parents jobs i've
also lived in singapore
shanghai the uk and i came to the us for
university
and started working there as well and
now i am in montreal
but we'll be moving back to the us
pretty soon so
i mean when people ask me where i'm from
i feel like i can't really answer
without giving like a a two-minute
explanation but yeah i mean i like to
talk about
politics as well social issues and
cultural issues
too because i feel like for the longest
time the right and the conservatives
which is kind of the angle that i come
from have largely overlooked that sphere
which has been detrimental to the
movement
okay solid response uh before we get
started how
what was living in singapore like i've
always wanted to
i'm i did a bunch of traveling this year
not for fun unfortunately
right um but i've always looked at
singapore and thought that looks
really nice so what is it like it is it
is
so beautiful uh so clean and so safe of
course politically it's
it's essentially a benevolent
dictatorship and i was about 14
when i was living there so i wasn't
really keyed into the politics of what
was happening around me but
i remember that i i could go out with my
friends
to the equivalent of the downtown
singapore is very small but you know i
could go out with my friends and my
parents would never worry that anything
would happen to me because it was
it's such a safe place there um you know
english speaking
it's it's a former british colony so
coming from hong kong it was it was kind
of similar
in that regard it's asian but very
westernized and
it was beautiful it's been a number of
years since i've been back and i really
miss it especially the weather
the only thing that's kind of strange
there is that instead of like
you might have mice problems in north
america there were lizard
issues like there's lizard repellent
that you have to spray in your house
because you get all these little lizards
running everywhere but no it was it was
a great time and i still i really love
singapore
i feel like lizards i feel like that's
an improvement over mice for some reason
is it no i i agree i don't know to me
they seem cleaner
than than mice they do seem maybe they
don't spread disease as much i
don't know if that's true or not that
would be my inclination too because
i mean at least they're not rodents and
yeah i do feel like they're definitely
an improvement
but the only thing is that they like
they kind of slither everywhere and
they're super super fast so they're a
little bit they're harder to catch than
mice it's the only thing
i went to new york earlier this year and
i stayed in this
like never stay in an airbnb in
manhattan
now i know but i stayed in an airbnb and
it was in this
really run-down apartment building
and it had cockroaches which i haven't
experienced i've only experienced like
the little ones that
they're little these were like these
were huge
and it turns out they fly oh my god
i called oh my god it was horrible i
didn't i did leave but i was like this
is
it was funny because i was so freaked
out but they're like
are you safe i called airbnb they're
like are you in a safe place and i was
like wow
yes but i'm really uncomfortable yeah
no kidding that's i would rather lizards
over cockroaches any day especially
flying ones that just that's even more
terrifying
i don't know i didn't see it fly but i
looked them up and it was like they fly
and i was like that's it
you're not even safe anywhere they can
get you wherever that's awesome yeah
yeah
yeah so you're in montreal right now
mm-hmm
very so what's what's uh montreal like
other than weather like what's it like
with the
covid restrictions oh very very
totalitarian actually uh right now we
are under curfew
from 8pm to 5am you cannot go out for
the past i think it's two weeks all
non-essential businesses have been
closed uh today is actually the first
when we're filming this the first day
that non-essential businesses can open
but uh gyms and restaurants are still
closed so it's been
it's been really really tough living
here and it's funny in the u.s there's
this whole debate about like oh well if
we would have just worn masks this would
be over by now
but i mean montreal has been wearing
masks since this summer and we never
really opened up fully and yet it feels
like things are only getting
worse and more restrictive so i mean
it's kind of been
a black pill as to the effectiveness of
so many of these measures and i mean
it's not like i i think
it's no big deal you can just go around
licking doorknobs or everything like
that no of course you know be cautious
wash your heads
stay home if you're sick but uh yeah i
just really don't see
the efficacy of of all of these measures
especially if they they say
things only keep getting worse the more
restrictions they put in place
for for toronto i actually might
switch with you at the moment really
yeah we do we do not have a curfew but
right now we have
it's strongly recommended that you stay
at home so you're allowed to go outside
to exercise
they're not really giving you tickets
right um right but you're not allowed to
see
family right you have to stay isolated
but
non-essential businesses have been
closed since november
27th i think i could be off by a few
days
yeah so i'm going like
i'm going absolutely nuts in here it was
like at least i have work and i have the
podcasts and things but
things are not good and there's like
news that they're going to start
reopening maybe but even elementary
schools like everything was closed and
it's been
months now with no end so a curfew is
bad what if you have a dog
are you allowed to go out if you have a
dog yeah you're allowed to go out if you
have a dog but you can only walk it
within i think one kilometer
of your house and it's i mean the police
here
will stop you i know this cop cause
actually he's a normal person and
he he's a he's a good guy you know a lot
of the times he'll just give people
warnings say hey you can't do this but i
don't want to
give you a ticket because i understand
it's kind of outrageous but
no he says that they're under orders
like after 8 pm to stop
every single car that they see and ask
them if they have
a valid reason look at the documentation
and things like that which is it's so
scary and
like we my grandmother she's in toronto
with my aunt and my mom has just been
dying to go see them for months and
months and months but with all the
restrictions we haven't and it's just
it's frustrating it's like so close yet
so far
yeah it's pretty depressing i really
hope it'll lessen up soon
it's pretty sad it's very sad um how's
your family how's your dad
oh thank you so much for asking um so
for anyone who's maybe not familiar with
the situation my dad
was diagnosed with cancer liver cancer
last year and it was this whole
hullabaloo with
the quebec healthcare system you know i
i've only ever lived in quebec and
canada so i can't really speak for
how it works in ontario but i know in
quebec at the best of
times the the weights are are very very
long and then you kind of add covet on
top of that
i think the the premier said that around
35
of like procedures and surgeries have
been delayed and
you know that's already kind of on top
of the regular delay you might already
have
so i mean it was like pretty it was
months and months and months between the
time he actually got the scan and we
finally got the diagnosis
and then we were waiting for a surgery
date and one just never came so we
actually ended up going to seek
treatment in the u.s
which we were very fortunate to be able
to do had to crowdfund for a surgery
which people were unbelievably generous
they got out the tumor nasty looking
thing and
now he's back and the the trouble has
been trying to
get follow-ups for screenings in a
timely manner
because again it's just it's hard here
like he got back in
i think end of october beginning of
november and we were trying
essentially from day one because we knew
it would be a wait
trying to get him to refer to a
specialist to do screenings as soon as
we got here
and you know it was supposed to be he
would get a screening
after in three months just to make sure
he was cancer clear
we finally had it just done last week so
that's uh
almost like four months after but at
least it got done and now
hopefully we'll get results back that
he's cancer-free
um but you know in terms of the canadian
healthcare system
i it's probably no big deal i had a
biopsy done of a little
mole thing on my scalp in december i had
to wait a year
to get a dermatologist appointment then
once i finally did
i had to go back in four months to see
if it had grown and then
once it apparently had got a little bit
funky he wanted to remove it i had to go
back two months later
and now it's been like no like eight
weeks that i've been waiting to get the
results back
for that biopsy and i'm again i'm sure
it's fine but
yeah i feel like just the the past year
and i'm sure your family
can relate to this it's just been a
whole bunch of frustrations having to do
with you know family health yeah well i
can't imagine
during covid times i mean we just like
with my dad we just left
we're like ah we're not dealing with
this with this country
but um i know it's been really hard for
people during copa times and yeah i had
trouble with the
canadian health system healthcare system
is is
great for people who don't have any
money because those people are
totally [ __ ] in other countries right
and at least you get
care eventually right but for people who
have like
acute problems and there's no fast
tracking it when really it needs to be
fast-tracked it's
really a complete disaster like with my
this wasn't exactly life and death um
when i had my ankle done they gave me a
three and a half year
wait to get surgery and i was like
suicidal with pain
then yeah of course so and it was like
what this this is how it is um
so people who aren't like forced into
the system sometimes they don't
understand how
slow and disorganized it is um
but i guess there are upsides and
downsides i mean if you have money or
like thank god you guys did crowdfunding
and stuff um and got to the states but
brutal brutal year huh you're totally
right about there being upsides and
downsides and it's frustrating because i
feel like whenever i
kind of criticize the canadian
healthcare system and these are usually
criticisms that
pretty much every canadian has about
things like disorganization and wait
times um
people assume it's like me saying we
should get onto the american system it's
like i don't know anyone who's defending
the american system
but i think it'd be naive to say that
there's no problems here or like other
countries with single-payer systems and
it's i've also had
issues with i don't know i feel like the
diagnostic approach in canada
is also pretty different um you know in
terms of like
if if they don't know what's wrong with
you i've had trouble
um trying to get doctors to take
initiatives
initiative to do more screenings and
testing for potential issues i've had
health problems myself and it's been an
uphill battle trying to get a definitive
diagnosis
i i feel like they're you know they feel
like oh if you could still
kind of manage then you're probably fine
which i mean it doesn't feel like the
case when you're actually going through
that illness
yeah that might be um i've been because
of various health problems i've been
all around the world dealing with them
and honestly that seems to pretty much
be the norm everywhere i think that's
just confusion
because health is so complicated but
yeah
canada has that plus it's really slow
like
any time you go somewhere and you pay
then you're a customer
and you're treated differently and
that's just how it is so
at least people should be aware if they
have money then there are options
elsewhere that can be fast-tracked
and weirdly enough like well we'll get
off of health because i want to keep
this like upbeat i'm all grumpy today so
i'm
like try to keep the podcast upbeat but
i did have some
like scans and things done in the us
when i was looking for an ankle
replacement
and it was cheaper than i thought it was
gonna be like like i had this idea that
i'd go there and get an x-ray and it
would cost
me you know 400 just for that
and it i know people get totally [ __ ]
there
but it wasn't as much as i thought for
what i had done and one surgeon
did the he couldn't help me and he told
me when i went there we talked for like
an hour and a half and he said he
couldn't help me and he didn't charge
anything
so i guess it depends if you if you get
completely screwed or not but it's not
always
a ton of money if you have some um yeah
changing changing topics um
you have a show so can you tell me a
little bit about your show and the plans
for your show cause
i heard that you left blaze yes i
bet about that so i was with i first
started out making videos independently
on youtube and then after about maybe a
year and a half i
signed on with crtv which was amazing
and actually have stephen crowder to
thank for that because he kind of
introduced them to my videos
um and then i was with them for about a
year and then crtv
mers merged with the blaze giving us
blaze tv
and i was with them for two more years
and i know anytime someone like
leaves a network or something people
want to know is there bad blood is there
anything juicy
nothing like that at all you know i i
love the people at the blaze still a
huge fan of their mission and their
shows and
i i hope to have a lot of my i guess
former fellow co-hosts on my new show
uh but you know there there are other
things that i've been wanting to do
and i do have a new show in the works
that's going to be premiering the first
week of march
that i'm very very excited for and we're
going to be just
on all platforms we're gonna be on
youtube facebook
with full episodes as well as rumble bit
shoot and minds cause i just
i mean youtube is is brutal if you're
talking about politics a lot of time and
if you're not an authoritative source
right now we're not on the audio only
platforms but we will be going to them
you know itunes spotify google play
and there's also going to be some tv
aspects involved for this if you're one
of the people that actually has cable
in this day and age that i'm very very
excited about so it's it's definitely
uh you know there's still content that's
gonna be coming out there's even more
content that's gonna be coming out so
i'm i'm looking forward to it and uh you
know i i love politics
talk about it a ton but i've also
started a
media channel focusing more on movies tv
shows pop culture and that sort of thing
called mediaholic and that's also kind
of a nice change of pace because i feel
like
i can really get burned out on politics
i'm sure you probably feel the same way
so it's nice to be able to talk about
something else and you know there's more
to me than just politics so it's fun
getting to explore that
yeah it's stressful i'm not even uh i
don't even really talk politics like i
don't
talk you i feel like you and your father
get dragged into politics though
like i agree like you're i don't see
like your father is political but i feel
like people are always politicizing him
which i
would be even more exhausted well i mean
they do that to
if you have any type of following i mean
you get people acting
asking actors who they're going to vote
for and then they become this
like even people on the left like i know
billy eilish came out
and said you know i'm voting for biden
you should vote for biden but like
i don't know anything in i don't know
any of the background there
but it seems to me that somebody on the
biden team probably came to her
rather than her being like you know what
i want to do with my time
politics right so i think some people
who
maybe have followings get kind of
dragged into it it's like what's your
opinion on this contentious subject
see if we can get you there um but it's
definitely
stressful so i can see where you're
coming with uh maybe i'll branch out a
little bit have a lighter day
yeah no for sure and i mean it kind of
reminds me of taylor swift like for the
longest she's political now but for the
longest time she wasn't
and people were complaining that she
wasn't using her platform
to advocate for whatever causes they
were passionate about
and you know i feel like even not being
political
is a political statement now i mean you
have actors like gina carano who's
all she's pretty much done is stand up
against cancel culture but now she's
been branded as like this pro-trump
right-wing figure even though i mean
there's nothing innately
right-wing about standing up against
cancel culture and it's just this it's
this
confusing headache on social media and
like you said it's nice to have a little
bit of a lighter side
every now and then yeah yeah definitely
um where do you okay okay here's kind of
a fun question
um where do you stan what issues are you
right-wing on
and what issues are you left wing on
that's a that's a good question when it
comes to just like one or two
yeah when it comes to economics i'm
definitely like right wing smaller
government
fewer regulations more economic freedoms
like lower taxes
and all of that um especially like
growing up in hong kong there's 15
percent flat tax for
corporations and individuals that's very
very nice i did not know that
yeah and it's i mean you know it's not
like there's no roads
or no health care system there is it's
just managed very very well
and it's a very business friendly
environment so i obviously it's kind of
like a city state so it's a bit
different than talking about an entire
country
of how you would manage that budget but
i find it a very interesting case study
and then in terms of like what i'm
left-wing about it's kind of hard to
talk about now because i feel like
you know a lot of the loudest activists
who are on the left
they're more advocating for far-left
policies which
i i don't agree with um let's see well
something that i've gotten kind of flack
for is
you know using preferred pronouns when
it comes to people like
blair white or if i'm trying to
respectfully engage in a conversation
with someone and i want to hear their
opinion
i have gotten i guess criticized from my
right wing audience for that but it's
like look i'm not saying that i agree
with their entire interpretation
of gender but i want to bring this
person to the table
so this is a concession that i'm willing
to make in the hope that it shows that i
respect their point of view
and you know that i am willing to do a
give and take and
i mean sometimes when it's people who
pass i just find it easier so that's
that's something that i've been
criticized for especially like you know
when it comes to lgbt issues i'm just
very much of the you know
if it doesn't affect me then it i i
don't make a big deal out of it
and now when i do videos talking about
lgbt issues i'm often talking about the
activist portion of that community not
the everyday portion of people who just
you know identify however but i feel
like a lot of people aren't able to
distinguish those two things you know
talking
about the political activist versus the
everyday gay or lesbian person
so yeah i i guess that kind of sums it
up
yeah that makes sense very well said uh
what did you take in university out of
curiosity
um so i actually am one of the few
people who studied poli-sci
and is also kind of working in poli-sci
uh i i did political science and my
minor was middle east studies and
arabic so i spent like two years
learning a language that i have
essentially forgotten now but
um but yeah it's interesting when i was
in university i always figured i would
end up as like an analyst or something
or military intelligence
then i ended up learning that because i
had lived so many places that was
actually a kind of a security
issue and so things didn't work out but
i
am um you know i'm glad that i studied
what i did
i'm i'm kind of critical now of a lot of
university programs but
personally from my experience i do
believe that my degree
helped me in my field and taught me a
lot
and i was also lucky enough to get
things like scholarships
so i didn't graduate hugely in debt um
especially from an american college
which is you know
so much more expensive than canadian
colleges because they're so highly
subsidized in
in canada okay well that's good to hear
uh when were you in university four
years
that's okay so i'm 26 now and i
graduated when i was 20.
and i started i i think i ended up doing
my degree in like three years i know
it feels so strange saying that it was
like six
years ago because it doesn't feel like
six years ago and that really really
dates me but i know like even
whenever i see any of these um like
evergreen protests or even the first
video i ever saw
of of your dad i mean i don't mean to
sound like an old person but like it
wasn't like that in my day like when i
was at university and it feels like
campuses have have gone so so quickly
radical it's like
an entirely different world than the one
that i was in when i was studying i mean
mine was i went to concordia in montreal
no concordia yeah i didn't know that
that's so i know so many people who went
to concordia i had no idea
i assumed you would have gone to like u
of t or something
no um i having the hip and ankle
replacement screwed up my sciences i
wanted to go into psychology
um but at u of t it's a you it's a
bachelor of science
okay um and because i missed i missed
two half years getting my hip and ankle
replaced so
basically i missed two years so i would
have had to take two years of extra high
school and i was like
[ __ ] bad like hard no so i went to
concordia for psychology
because it's a bachelor of arts um and i
ended up actually leaving concordia
because i got really sick but also
because it started to get radicalized
faster i think because it's an art
school things got weird in there and i
could kind of see what was going on and
i was like i'm not paying and
i'm born in montreal so i paid like
nothing for tuition it was
right i think it was 2 700 either a
semester or for the year
like it really didn't cost very much but
i was paying for courses like
i take a course on homer and it would be
homer through the feminist perspective
like for a
feminist lens once you got there after
you'd paid
and i was like this is this is like
homer i don't want to be learning this i
didn't pay for this
um and then it started happening i took
a couple of history courses and they
were weird and i was like you know what
i'm going to go into sciences because
this is getting weird
and that was 2012 maybe or 2011
cause i went a little bit late because
of the hip and ankle replacement
um so i saw things but but still
nothing like what we're seeing now or at
least
what we're seeing on youtube about what
universities are like
um what do you think do you think
there's you like what what should
young people do um is university still a
good idea does it depend on what you
study should they be doing something
else well i think it definitely depends
on where you go
and what you study uh you know if you
want
for example to study
and get an english degree i mean i
totally understand that like the passion
side of that if you're interested in the
field but especially if you're in the
u.s there are cost benefits
to kind of way with you know the
expected return
on that degree and i feel like we we
kind of fail
kids or students a lot throughout high
school because there's not really a lot
of like career coaching
or exploration that's available to
children unlike you know a lot of
european especially scandinavian
countries where their education system's
so much better than canada or the us
there's there's a lot
more attention being paid to okay what
are your strengths
as an individual what can you do where
you can excel on them versus trying to
shove everybody through the exact same
program
and not really giving them any guidance
of what they can or cannot do with their
skills
i think i i think that i mean you know
older generations like to make
fun of college students who graduate in
debt with
like literature degrees but it's like
well what what have your generation what
has your generation done
to help them to make that better
decision and right now it's not anything
so
you know i think if you're interested in
stem definitely a university degree is
probably not only worth it but necessary
but i mean if you're interested in for
example something
like politics or writing i would
really strongly consider something like
independent study and
you know if you're not inclined in terms
of like test taking
or a lot of school subjects that doesn't
mean that there isn't
there aren't educational opportunities
available we don't talk a lot about
vocational training
you know in canada and the us even
though like those are huge fields a lot
of them are way more secure and
surprisingly
lucrative and there's no
it's not like graduating with some art
degree
and in debt makes you somehow better
than uh
you know electrician who's making like
six figures a year and has a stable job
in his own company
but i feel like that's that's kind of
the narrative that's pushed on to a lot
of
children it can make you feel like
you're better
yeah exactly you could feel like you're
better as you
i don't know serve coffee at starbucks
with your student loans
yeah it's really it's really
unacceptable i think i went to uh
an arts high school too and a lot of
that
which was honestly total [ __ ] was
just follow your dreams and try really
hard and you'll make it right and it was
like
you'll make it being somebody who
produces films
and like nobody who produces films make
it i mean
arguably social media has made it a
little bit easier
um but but still it's it's hard um
and you're not really told you're not i
wasn't told the business aspect at all
and that was partly because i went to an
art school
probably partly because my parents are
also kind of artistically inclined like
my dad's
you know intellectual professor and my
mom is
basically an artist so i wasn't told hey
like this is what makes money but having
schools or doing research yourself and
figuring out
what actually makes money is really
useful because once you have
money then you have some freedom and
then if you want to pursue something
artistic at least you have a backup plan
instead of just being screwed and
and it's unfair right if you end up
taking courses in university and you end
up
in debt with a useless degree then no
wonder you're angry especially if
everything you've learned has told you
that that's what was gonna work out
like it's not that surprising that we
have people who are like
screw society it's somebody else's fault
because i just did what i was
told was gonna work no definitely and i
mean these colleges play into it
um they really push it on their students
like no like this is the best place to
study excel in your field they don't
often talk about
employment and people have raised good
points that in the us at 18 like you're
young enough to agree
to hundreds of thousands of in some
cases of dollars worth of debt but you
can't
drink it it is kind of upside down and i
just wish there was this bigger focus
kind of like you were saying on the
business side of things and on
entrepreneurialism because
i mean for a lot of people if you are
entrepreneurial about it you can make a
living off of your art you know there's
graphic designs there's way to market
your product especially
with social media and the internet where
you can find an audience i think easier
than ever before and potentially make a
living off of it
but i i would love to see more programs
that are focused in the arts
kind of try to merge those two markets
and one of one of the things that i love
is like makeup makeup
youtube social media i'm all i'm all
into that but that's been one of the
most interesting places where i look and
it's like this community of creatives
who have also tapped into this extremely
lucrative market by being
entrepreneurial about it and it's
amazing because you have all of these
like
makeup artists instagram stars who are
making millions of dollars who probably
when they were in
makeup school were getting made fun of
from picking something stupid that's
never going to make them any money but
because they were entrepreneurial about
it
now they're richer than like essentially
everybody
that's a very good point actually so
there are ways to go about it but you
have to be a certain type of person to
be capable of that yeah
entrepreneurial because some people
aren't inclined to do that but a lot of
people
are and don't know it and
yeah even like you said something for
visual art also i think
i think when you go into those visual
art programs i was in visual arts in
high school
and i didn't pursue that in university
because i thought that's not a good idea
yeah but uh if you are really inclined
to do things
that way then it's too bad that
marketing and that kind of stuff is kind
of look
down on because it could be how you make
your money and how
you make visual art worth doing
monetarily anyway
yeah and i feel like maybe for for some
art schools or artists they might look
at that as kind of like selling out or
being too
uh which but i mean it's you know
there's nothing wrong with trying to
marry your passion with
just being realistic that oh we still
need to pay bills and eat food
food is good food is good it was good
so how so the last year's been super
stressful for you not just the pandemic
but also health
crises um how have you been staying
sane staying calm even during this like
lockdown
in montreal are there things you do yeah
well it's been it's been a roller
coaster i remember the first when
lockdown first started like that first
month was super super hard on me i was
just like i missed
going places that i still miss going
places but i feel like now
and this is kind of a good and bad thing
it's like i don't know you're numb to it
like it's been so long like this you're
like what is it even to go
out and eat at a restaurant what like
what what do my friends even look like
in person i don't remember
um you know i'm i'm lucky that like
where i live
like i have my family with me so i'm a
lot less
isolated in my day-to-day than i know
some other people are and i've been
really really thankful for that
and kind of like you i you know i have
my
work that i can do from home so i've
still been able to like
engage in that and it's yeah i mean
essentially it's just been
a lot of working and over over the past
year it's kind of it's been a bit of a
mixed bag my mom was
starting her own like soap bath and body
company
yeah and so it's like you know for
the the past year it's been frustrating
because a lot of the in-person avenues
for like selling and growing the company
have not been accessible and you know a
lot of we
have played around with selling
wholesale and like a lot of like
businesses
are not buying they're not looking for
new products but it's
it's been good it's given us time to
kind of like work on the brand
on the product and everything like that
on the packaging which was like my
domain
so it's been fun like we've we've found
ways to
at least try to keep busy and even
though it's been hard i think overall
my family has managed to have it a lot
better than i know a lot of other people
um and then it's been kind of hard to
see and this is coming from a place of
like i'll check my privilege here
someone who still has a job in this
um seeing other people who are probably
in similar situations as i am kind of
advocating for no this is no big deal
let's stay like this forever it's like
okay well just because you and i still
have jobs
doesn't mean that everyone else does um
one of the things that has been hard
though is like the not being able to
travel
for work traveling used to be a huge
part of what i was doing i was in the us
uh you know for different events
probably at the busiest point every
other week
and now it's kind of like all of that
has stopped and i don't foresee those
events starting back up like
any anytime soon um and yeah i mean even
like i
before things kind of go more south with
china i would love to be able to go back
to hong kong sometime this year but
i don't know if that's going to be able
to happen i got married this year we
would love to do it congratulations
thank you yeah um it wasn't really much
of a wedding because of
covid restrictions but it happened and
you know we
yeah we would love to be able to have
some sort of celebration with all our
family members and friends and
go to greece but i i guess there's so
much that's just kind of on pause right
now
yeah have you heard that obviously you
have heard
that if you go to the states or go
anywhere outside of canada when you come
back you have to spend three days in a
hotel even if you're negative
for covid or vaccinated three days to
wait for your
covet test and you're stuck in your room
there's a guard in the hall
and the food is a sandwich in water
three times a day
you can't get uber eats or whatever it's
on your dime i've heard like you haven't
had and it costs
two two grand for these three days
otherwise you go to jail
it's insane and i i saw like when
trudeau was announcing that that he even
admitted only around two percent or
something of covet cases in canada have
been traced
to air travel so it's like then
why why and i just like i i
i love so much about canada and canadian
culture
but something that does frustrate me is
that i feel like we take
too much like we're too nice sometimes
like i feel like we have to be like no
no more of this because you know i we
have the tendency to
i guess go the path of least resistance
even when i think
we should probably be putting up some
resistance
yeah and i just read an article because
he was like this is only until april
30th and i was like
yeah okay like other countries that have
this they haven't gotten rid of it even
if they don't have any cases so don't
don't give us that
um and then i just read a article
recently that it's oh until
2022 like and i was like
that's that's so not okay
yeah but i didn't look at the the border
with the u.s like the driving a lot of
people don't know that the border
closure between canada and the us
being my head of my hand on my table
that only applies to like driving over
like you can still
fly in between the us and canada but the
whole i mean there's a ton of traffic
that goes through the land border and
that's been closed since like
i think this summer and you know my
brother lives in yeah earlier even i
think earlier i think you're right
i think maybe may or april yeah maybe i
think like spring yeah i think you're
right yeah um
and yeah my brother lives in boston i
would love to be able to go visit him
but
i don't foresee them opening really
anytime soon which is
crazy because at first when it happened
they were like no it'll just be like
a month and two months and it seems like
any time we get closer to the
expiry date they just end up extending
it
yeah so you can you can't drive over and
you haven't been able to
since i don't know between april and
june
you can fly over but you have to stay in
a hotel and it is not a hotel
right like i've um i have a friend whose
husband worked on the renovations
for the hotels it's like a little jail
right there's plastic everywhere you get
brought from the airport to the hotel
in a like armed vehicle
um and threatened with jail if you don't
do it and
it's i don't know i don't see it going
away either
even if things open up it's so crazy
like a year ago i never would have
imagined that we would be here and i
know
i saw a poll saying that something like
87 percent of quebecers want to ban
international travel entirely
so it's like what are we are we gonna
like have exit visas soon or something
like you're not allowed to leave the
country that's
it's insane well also who are they
getting this information from like there
was a youtube video put up by
some news in montreal like one of the
main news sources and they were
interviewing people at the airport and
they had three interviews
and the interviews were like yeah well
you know the hospital
sorry not the hospital the hotel thing
doesn't seem that unreasonable i mean
two thousand dollars is a lot but we're
trying to stay safe
and i was just like how many people did
you interview to find these guys
like this is so this this is just pure
propaganda
because most people i think unless i'm
really in a bubble which i could be but
i don't
think most people are okay with this
like if you if you take an uber which
you're still allowed to do
if you're if you're going to work it's
iffy uber still exists
but uh and you talk to the uber drivers
everyone's very careful about mentioning
it but if you prod around a little bit
especially i've seen if they're
immigrants or have been elsewhere
they're they end up being like yeah this
is absolutely insane
so i haven't met very many people i've
met a few that are like no this is for
safety but most people don't think so
but they're not doing anything anyway
they're just like it'll go away we'll
wait and
hopefully it just will but yeah taking a
while
yeah i hope that it'll be gone you know
maybe even by the fall as i've heard
some people try to try to float around
but
my fear is that with so many of these
measures it's like once they get the
power and once we accept that it's
acceptable for them to do
there's not really much incentive to
kind of do away with it i mean an
example that my husband brings up all
the time is that the income tax
at least in the us was originally
introduced as a temporary measure
just never went away and i feel like
because there's like this
almost cult of virtue signaling around
kovid like you're you're made out to be
a bad person if you have any doubts
like you said i think a lot of people
more than would initially
voice this are skeptical of this and
they're not that they don't want people
to be safe but they
they think things are going overboard i
think they're really less inclined
to voice those opinions publicly because
they know they're going to be shamed for
it it's not acceptable
to doubt anything because then you're
going to be branded like a grandma
killer kova denier
you know you know the drill kofi denier
yeah yeah
yep pretty sad hopefully it ends
hopefully you know at the rate we're
getting vaccines out it will never end
but uh
yeah okay okay another question what you
probably know this what does your
audience look like
who are the people who watch you mainly
yeah so my audience is it's mostly
male um it's about 70 to 75 percent
male which i think is pretty uh pretty
usual for like a youtube
political audience and they're young the
biggest age demographic is like 25 to 35
and then kind of below that around the
same number of like 18
to 25 year olds as well as like 35 to 45
year olds
so pretty young and it's it's really
it's interesting because it's like i've
noticed that across different platforms
you get a different spread
of people like i feel like on on
twitter i feel like i have more females
that interact with my content as well as
like instagram
than strictly youtube and i've just
started mirroring entire
like videos of mine on facebook and i
feel like the the people there are older
so you get like these different you get
different
feedback depending on what platform you
post to
and like you know if i if i post a video
to like bit shoot everybody's like super
edgy and red built
so it's it's kind of cool um but i i am
pretty lucky in that i feel like
not i mean a good portion of the people
who
at least comment on my video aren't even
necessarily people who agree with me
which is encouraging at least that
someone in this day and age would
like not only want to watch something
from a different perspective but also
engage in it mostly respectfully so i
find that encouraging
yeah that's really nice to hear yeah i
found that i found that for me
yeah i found with facebook it's older
people
um i haven't actually looked at twitter
i kind of avoid twitter
that's smart i'm on it sometimes when i
get angry just when i get angry about
something i'm like i'll put this out
into the twitter sphere
but uh otherwise i just kind of avoided
i don't really like twitter
uh but i have noticed me neither
facebook is
older i haven't looked into bit shoot or
any of the smaller platforms very much
uh i like telegram i love telegram yeah
i just started it and
i was kind of i i created an account not
my own channel but i created an account
to follow a bunch of people that got
de-platformed from twitter and i like
did not understand the user interface
yeah i was like
really really confused for a long time
but then like once i got the hang of it
i like it so much more than twitter now
because it's like it's almost like just
it's like being
in a group chat but you're the only one
who can type
i mean people can leave comments but
it's like the feed is just you so i like
to think of it as like i'm just texting
people
when i post on my channel and people are
just texting me when they post on their
channel
i don't i like it yeah i like it better
than twitter too
for sure you have your main channel for
anyone who's not on telegram you can
you can set up a channel if you want
which is like lauren said you can just
it's like twitter but it's just you
tweeting these things or
posting whatever and then you have
followers on that channel and they can
comment on each post
you can also make discussion groups so
then you get these huge
group chats which can devolve into chaos
very quickly but
it's kind of fun to
actually talk to people yeah it's it's
kind of if
like a blog and twitter had a baby
that's kind of like telegram
and i really like it i hope it i hope it
doesn't get shut down next i'm kind of
worried about that though i've already
seen that
talking about suing them for like
enabling anti-semitism or whatever
well i'm sure someone on there is
enabling anti-semitism
but i mean those those people are
everywhere
i don't know if it can get shut down uh
telegrams i think it's just it's
controlled by russians
and located in somewhere that seems a
little bit more untouchable
so we'll see uh what are your plans for
the future other than this
show do you have anything else up and
coming
so in the future we'll definitely have a
move
that's coming up this summer which i'm
so excited for i can't wait to get
out of montreal um and i'm also hoping
that you know got married this year
hoping that like sometime this year
maybe more toward the fall
we can you know get get a baby on board
that would be really exciting
yeah for sure and i feel like this is
gonna be like i don't know that the next
year is gonna be
a pretty big one for me in terms of like
starting a family so i'm
i'm excited for that i'm really really
excited about that like i love
what i do i love the content but it's um
you know it's definitely not the thing
that matters most to me so that's really
exciting and um well something that i
have in common with you
and this is actually largely because of
you i've also tried the carnivore diet
as well and i felt amazing i've never
felt
so good uh you know i have like wow
nothing super serious but minor health
concerns um and i think leading up
i i don't think i would do it during
pregnancy but like leading up to
pregnancy i want to be
like in the best possible shape that i
can be in terms of working out and just
feeling
strong so i'm thinking that uh you know
leading up to it i might try to get back
on it again and the reason why i stopped
eventually was because i was traveling
so much and it was just getting a little
bit hard to make sure i was eating
enough
and eating what i should be but yeah i
did notice that when i went off of it
like all the health problems that i had
anxiety trouble sleeping getting sick
all the time everything came back
which was very very sad i just want cake
to be healthy
and carved so sad
yeah i just want cake to be healthy too
yeah
yeah well that's interesting um yeah and
i think i think one of the good parts of
the diet too
is you can kind of simplify it down and
then you can figure out what makes you
feel
good or bad and then you can avoid those
things
um so that's that's good i'm glad that
it's helped
no it definitely has yeah that's great
how long did you try it out for
so probably like three months
or something like that and um i i went
back on it again
and you know again with just the meat it
was feeling really really great
and i i was okay with any type of meat
like i was eating
pork beef chicken lamb seafood all of
that
was really really fine um i like
reintroduced
uh fruit sparingly and that was okay for
some reason like
the greens were like worse than the
fruit for me um
dairy was also not good i know some
people um like on reddit there's a
pretty big
forum of like you have carnivores zero
zero carbs some people do milk and dairy
products and they're fine
that was not me and i found out maybe i
overdid it because i
i ate so much cheese one day i was like
yeah let's do this but
i my big problem is that i have trouble
slowly reintroducing like once i kind of
fall off the wagon i'm just like
okay i want everything so it's like you
know if i were to do it again
that would be something that i need to
work harder on because i really do want
to know what
exactly um is my issue and uh
you know if i do it again i've also
talked to
i i got this really great doctor
eventually in canada who
didn't look at me like i was crazy when
i told him that i was doing this
that's shocking yeah no it really was
because i even asked him like
how long should i stay on this like do
you think it's okay and he was a
specialist in internal medicine and i
went to him specifically to try to get a
diagnostic as to why i was sick all the
time like
what is it is it lyme disease is it some
sort of autoimmune thing and he's like
well you know our peanuts healthy is
what he asked me and i said
yeah i guess and he said but they're not
healthy if you're allergic to them
and i was like well that's a good point
and so he said you know if if you're
if you're eating something and it's
making you feel bad you need to stop
eating that
um and you know we've tested all my
blood levels and
i was still fine so he was actually um
surprisingly
encouraging of me which i was not
expecting i was expecting to be like
kind of put in in the same asylum or
something or like to be
not responsible enough because like on
the internet at least people look at you
like you're crazy when you tell them
about it uh like you're gonna die
immediately what but no he was he was
actually really great
uh he and he really understood like what
it was like and he
he's all up in the microbiome kind of
research
uh about like how what you eat affects
your cravings how you feel even your
brain functions so
it was it was a good experience
that's so nice to hear that's so nice to
hear
okay well good luck in the future with
that
thank you where can people find you
online
sure um so if you are on facebook
instagram or twitter i am at the lauren
chen
and i also post videos to youtube on two
different channels
lauren chen is for like politics and
more heavy stuff and then mediaholic is
if you enjoy
like movies or tv shows things like that
and i'm also
you know trying to make sure i don't
neglect all tech platforms so
[ __ ] shoot rumble and so far minds are
where i also post
i've had people also say stuff like what
about odyssey or like such and such
platform but it's it's great when
like those other platforms have direct
mirroring but sometimes it's like i
can't be
on every single platform when i have to
manually upload but
yeah it's uh if you're on those
platforms i encourage you to watch there
instead of youtube because screw youtube
okay well thank you lauren thank you
very much for coming on i've been
looking forward to talking to you and
e meeting you i'm sorry that you're also
in canada right now
definitely thank you so much for having
me and i hope you guys stay
warm up there it's i don't know about in
toronto but we've just been getting
crazy amounts of snow it is not nearly
as i
i went to university in montreal and
toronto is not even close to as bad as
montreal
um it's more about staying sane than
staying warm up here right now
yeah equally equally important you're
right yeah
well thanks again for sure
[Music]
you